that looks so intense you know incense
have you ever tried any of them well
thank you for asking that calyx I was
about to clarify for those who are
wondering if I was the really buff guy
in the tanktop
no I was the mildly out of shape guy
going because I have tried the course
and I'm an athlete
don't look at credulous here gentlemen I
played baseball in college yeah I would
not cheat you would be a good Ninja
Warrior we actually have footage of when
I tried to do it and there's a moment
where you can see here it is there's B
oh I got this too
that would be me I broke my foot doing
that now have I pins in my foot did you
really how many broken bones do you get
with you it's been amazing how we've
really only had a handful of bad
injuries and to a person once you're one
of them you're gonna do something be the
best that's your mom I was the best at
being the worst
you know I feel is the host my job is to
make the contestants look wonderful and
I took on a challenge in high heels
which I need to know more about okay
okay so I did I went on lip sync battle
with my parents in the audience and
[Music]
[Applause]
that is yes you're my favorite human
right now girl like that she's an icon
like what that was sheriff for those who
are wondering is it was that Silence of
the Lambs the musical no that was me and
Cher oh I'm a beaver now bravery I'm 64
I'm a little trimmer now I was 250 then
but I was probably six ten to fit
fishnets on with my impressive glutes
hanging out and best of all my 80 year
old parents were in the crowd getting to
watch dad going what happened to our son
the doctor where did he go and I just
said you know I think I was I was built
to be beautiful I was beautiful it's
remarkably confidence when you're
wearing these high heels and you got the
fishnets on and you're out there walked
out here they go just don't start
singing with Kelly and I met some people
have waited a lifetime for
look at Jennifer she's so nice she's
like I'm not going to be a part of this
Kelly Clarkson but the season finale of
ninja Wars coming up at number 16 are
there any like really cool moments so I
will let you guys know this we don't
like to do spoilers but we have a winner
we have a winner a million dollar
champion this is just the second time in
the show's history somebody completes
all four stages now for those who don't
know this is our 11th season we've only
had one winner this this is unlike this
isn't American Idol where they go nobody
won so folks see you next year we have a
clip of the first mom to hit the buzzers
so let's watch
[Applause]
I mean I'm so impressed by you
like Geert like you said not everybody
wins right winner and she's like a mama
land it down like I can't even get on a
treadmill half the time like I can't
like you're insane like what what kind
of impact does it man in your life after
winning well I think they're so
distressing ya covered those are even
more distracting our mind I'm doing a
couple loans yeah yeah but how is it
changed your life you know it was
incredible it was amazing it was this
big dream you know four years ago I
heard there was no mom had ever made it
through the course and hit a buzzer and
I thought we need to get him up there we
need to get a mom out there
I'm really glad it was me I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this